[Music]
well the Soviet bloc collapsed nearly 30
years ago but the Stasi lives on on your
nearest cause college campus more than
200 schools in this country maintain
what they call bias response teams their
job is to investigate thought crimes
that students may have committed in the
University of Michigan students are
urged to spy on their peers and make
anonymous reports if they see or hear
anyone using the wrong words or thinking
unapproved thoughts now the school is
being sued by advocates for the First
Amendment to point out that creepy
thought police probably violate the
First Amendment
Nikki Neely is president of speech first
which brought that lawsuit and she joins
us tonight to explain it
did i overstate that know your dad is
response to Isaac like sweep out of the
rafters to arrest you if you have an
unapproved thought yeah yes there is
actually an online portal on the
university of michigan web site where
you can report speech not even that you
have been subject to but that you have
overheard so maybe you and I are having
a conversation about a TV show we saw
last night somebody walks by they think
I don't like that word and they can go
and they can log in and they can make an
airport and then we'll have to go and
we'll be brought before the buyers
response team which is made up of
administrators and campus police and
we'll have to explain ourselves and we
have to talk to the police if someone
reports you for saying some things on
people so what if you say you know what
I'm not I'm not interested in this kind
of thing and I don't want to talk to you
and buzz off well you will be subject to
punishments which might include
remediation I think they call
restorative justice so that might be you
might have to go to cultural
appropriation training or some other
kind of diversity education unconscious
bias training which i hear is a thing
these days and you know that can go up
to and including Shinda pending on how
severe your transgression was so so you
have no power you have no power has
anyone before you pointed out that you
have an absolute right guaranteed in the
first item in the Bill of Rights the
First Amendment to the rights to say
what you think is true period yeah
there's been a lot of people that have
written about it the foundation for
individual rights and Education has done
terrific work what they show you where
are they on this they haven't waited on
this oh really
I thought they cared about free speech
though yeah they've stepped back from
that recently and so we decided to bring
a lawsuit we thought you know let's draw
thus and we have membership associations
so we have three students on the
university of michigan who are the
campus who are enrolled who have decided
let's push back so we'll be representing
them as our association because they're
scared with good reason they don't want
their names out there and so we're it's
speech first versus the University of
Michigan so what is the University's
position on this the first moment
doesn't exist or that it's not it
doesn't cover college campuses or do
they have an argument they haven't
responded to us yet we'll be filing for
a preliminary injunction so we hope to
pause all the programs until we can come
to some conclusion where the rights
actually are respected could you put the
university about a business and make
sure that it never rises again from the
ashes well as you said before there are
over 200 schools that have programs like
this in place well I hope you could I
hope you crushed them all because this
is a this is a threat to everything that
we stand for believe in that is holy
this is really a threat and I'm glad
that you're addressing it thank you
thank you